it's a good accessory from sophie Turner
and Joe Jonas to get Harrington and Rose
Leslie et is taking a look at the Game
of Thrones romances IRL should have told
you about him we followed the love lives
of some of our favorite characters
breakups reunions death and more but
it's easy to forget most of the
residents of Westeros don't date in real
life this is sort of just seems like an
added bonus except for one couple Kit
Harington and Rose Leslie who found an
off-screen connection because of their
on-screen characters I said to Rose the
other night I was like we've been
tethered by this show for a long time
we've loved it the on-screen lovebirds
made it official
off screen tying the knot at a game of
Thrones esque Castle in 2018 talk about
life imitating art it means so much to
have him here it's just like the best
support I have a shoulder to cry on so
it's good I'm so happy no she's not
talking about sonses on-screen
relationships Sophie Turner's gushing
over fiance a Joe Jonas the couple got
engaged in 2017 and are planning on
getting hitched in summer of 2019 during
the game of Thrones final season
premiere the actress revealed to eat see
that her on-screen sister Maisie
Williams will be her real-life maid of
honor I'm getting hot the bridesmaid
dress she could be one of your
bridesmaid that's just my maid of honor
on a chair I can't even be thinking
about that dress when I'm wearing
something like that
mazie will be in the wedding but who
will be her plus-one
Ruben Selby the actress sent the rumor
mill abuzz after she was spotted holding
hands with the communications director
in New York City but I'm just waiting
for it so like hit me like a freight
train
Emilia Clarke is seemingly single after
quietly breaking things off with
boyfriend and film director Charlie
McDowell earlier this year it's going to
be a really exciting next chapter while
Peter Dinklage has been married to wife
Erica Schmidt since 2005 and the couple
share two children together there's only
one wall that method and it is here
winter is fast approaching as the final
season of Game of Thrones premiers April
14th the quest for the Iron Throne will
be claimed once and for all
I promise to fight for the living
[Music]
[Music]